حكايتها ليست من وحي الخيال
انها واقعنا
هنا
يعني هذا الابن الطفل
الثاني
لم تتمكن من ايقاف دموعي وهي تتذكر تلك
الليالي القاسيه التي عاشتها وابنها في
السجن سيده يتيمه الابوين ارمله وام لطفل
رضيع لم يكن بمقدوريها دفع ايجار بيتها
فساومها مالك البيت على ذلك السقف الذي
يحميها وعندما لم تخضع لرغباته زج بها تحت
سقف السجن بتهمه باطله
يعني
اذا ما سويتش كده نقفل الباب
ولا باي شيء من الكلام
لا يوجد في اليمن قوانين وتشريعات خاصه
لملاحظه العنف ضد النساء والفتيات وحمايه
الناجيات منه لذا لا تجد النساء اليمنيات
سوى بعض الجمعيات المحليه ومنظمات المجتمع
المدني التي تعمل على تمكينه النوم
ومساعدتهن على تعلم بعض المهارات والمهن
ليستطيعن العيش من خلالها بكرامه
طبعا الحمد لله
رحت يعني
ادور مكان امامي يكون يعني وفي ناس ما
يستغلوني او ما يعترض
حكاياتك حكايتها
حكايتنا كلنا
لنرويها ونسمعها لعلنا ننهي العنف ضدها في
يوم قريب